welcome to this interview professor
Murray gell-mann well thank you
actually I don't know maybe I could
speak Swedish to you because the story
goes that when you got the news about
the Nobel Prize in 1969 in October you
prepared your speech in Swedish for the
December day when the price ceremony was
is it true well one thing about winning
this award is that it increases the
number of stories that people make up
about you yes this is one morning yes is
one more no what happened was that when
I talked at the banquet after the award
ceremony one paragraph was in Swedish
yes but you speak in lots of languages
how many languages you can well that's
not actually true that's another story
they make up about me I'm very
interested in languages and I know
something about the relations among
languages about the etymologies about
sound changes from one language to
another and so on and so forth very
interested in that and even helping a
little bit to work on it but as to
speaking languages any European waiter
could do much better than I okay you're
a physicist a physicist and I speak by
native language fairly well American
English I can speak French moderately
well lecture in it and so on but I do
make mistakes down there and Spanish
Italian are much weaker especially in
vocabulary Danish I can speak a little
bit but I and when I'm in Sweden I try
to convert it to Swedish with sometimes
with some success and sometimes was much
less success but your interesting
languages I would say but I can read
these I can read these languages
moderately well you have found that one
word that has got the fame I would say
and also was named in the Nobel price
and it is quark and quarks where does it
what does did it come from well let's
see in the citation for the award
it was barely mentioned but I did
propose that the neutron and proton and
their and the related barriers were
composed roughly speaking of three
quarks each and that the quarks were the
fundamental entities they're analogous
to the electron the neutron proton and
so on were not elementary the word was I
had first as a sound quark it might have
been spelled k wo RK for example but
then I thought it was the right sound
for the fundamental constituents of
nuclei sounds sounds good
quark but then I discovered the word
quark in Finnegan's Wake of James story
see right and with the number three also
and there are roughly speaking three
quarks to a nucleon or baryon and I
thought well perhaps I can use the
spelling there quar k so there it is
yeah so we have lived with works for
more than 30 years now yes but in you
have moved your interest from
theoretical physicist broader interest
of complexity simplicity and complexity
regularities and randomness yes yes and
this subject which I call plastics the
study of the simple in the complex
includes a good deal that has to do with
physics electives comes from the common
root of the word simple and the word
simplicity and the word complexity
without distinguished without specifying
whether you're talking about the simple
or the complex I used to work on the sub
only that is the fundamental laws of
nature which we believe are
fundamentally simple quarks are simple
right
yo but what we see around us a great
deal of individuality we see around us
adaptive evolution as in biological
evolution for example but also cultural
evolution the evolution of of ideas and
so on and so forth a great deal of
individuality these are not things that
one finds in the directly and the
fundamental laws of physics where for
example every electron is exactly
identical with every other electron in
the universe and where we believe at
least that the laws don't change with
time the fundamental laws are immutable
in fact some people now claim just in
the last few months that they have found
some evidence that some of the supposed
constants of nature are actually
changing very slowly but that's a if
true that would be a very slow
cosmological effect but in the world
around us we see lots of individuality
and a great deal a great many different
kinds of evolution and so on and so
forth and we see a lot of complexity so
where does that come from
and in my book Clarke in ok Akbar in the
quark what a Jaguar I I discussed this
question but the point is that the
fundamental laws are simple but they are
not deterministic even at the
fundamental level they're not
deterministic because of quantum
mechanics but besides that they fail to
be deterministic because no observer
anywhere in the universe can have access
to all the necessary information for
predicting the future you mean this
thinking they so every in other words
any observer sees only a coarse-grained
version of the unit
and the coarse-grained state at a given
time does not determine the
coarse-grained state at the next time
only probabilistically so we have to
look at all the alternative possible
histories of the universe as a branching
tree of possibilities with probabilities
at the branch at the branchings and the
great writer the Argentine writer Jorge
Luis Borgess wrote a story about
somebody who made a model of the
branching alternative histories of
alternative possible histories of the
universe in the form of a garden of
forking paths' convene this adonis kiss
a report on and this the this idea that
the alternative possible histories of
the universe coarse-grained of course
form a branching tree means that the
history that is actually seen is a is Co
determined by the simple fundamental
laws and by an inconceivably long
sequence of accidents or chance events
which can come out in various ways and
in advance one can predict only the
probabilities of the different outcomes
so there of course is the source of
complexity now some of these accidents
produce a great deal of regularity in
the future and those we can call frozen
accidents things that at least locally
in space and time create new
regularities in addition to the
fundamental laws now fundamental physics
relates to the basic laws but the rest
of physics and chemistry and especially
other sciences like biology and geology
and so on and observational astronomy
and so on all of these depend a great
deal on the accident
not just on the fundamental laws but on
the all the rest of the information that
contributes to the history of the
universe so how can you make models or
series of these histories that are based
on accidents well we the fundamental
laws give you the probabilities but you
have to add joy to that information a
lot of information about the accidents
that have already occurred and
especially these important ones which we
can call frozen accidents which create a
great deal of regularity in the future
and the by complexity then what I call
effective complexity we mean the length
of a very concise description of the
regularities of something if I change
the subject for what you have traveled
to the tropics and you were also engaged
in environmental issues
yes very much in trying to preserve the
heritage of biological diversity I'm
also somewhat interested in the
preservation of cultural diversity
although that involves a great many more
paradoxes and contradictions but I've
worked hard on trying to help with the
preservation of a biological diversity
around the world and of course on land
the greatest diversity is found in the
tropics and also the tropics are full of
poor and in many cases overpopulated
countries so these are the main
obstacles so the but what is most
important to preserve is the tropics at
least on land and also the dangers are
greatest in the tropics so a lot of our
work has concentrated on the tropics
I've worked mostly through the John D
and Catherine T MacArthur Foundation
based in Chicago this was maybe not so
bad for you to travel because they are
so interested in ornithology oh yes and
it was a very great field ornithologist
Ted Parker who
joined me in over a campfire in
Venezuela when we invented the idea of
the rapid assessment program it was then
quite useful in nature conservation the
idea is if a certain tract of land is
considered for possible preservation as
a national park or whatever how to
evaluate the diversity that's present
and the quality of the of the
environment to what extent is is this a
natural area worth preserving now the
old fashioned way of course of looking
at an area was to have skilled botanists
and skilled zoologists of various kinds
spent many years cataloging the various
species and their interactions with one
another and so on and so forth the
trouble is by the time you do that the
area may not exist anymore so what we
did was to champion the notion of having
certain very special field biologists
like Ted himself form teams to go in and
rather quickly and approximately to
evaluate the diversity and the quality
represented by the area I have one last
question about the birds what is your
dream bird enough that you would like to
encounter oh there are many species I've
seen less than four thousand out of 9600
or something like almost ten thousand
species that are recognized in the world
but there are a few special ones that it
would be wonderful to see the the congo
peacock for example which lives in congo
yes for a long time nobody could believe
that there was a peacock in africa and
nobody has seen it no outsider no you
peon had actually seen one alive until
requite reasonably so I saw them in the
Regent Park Zoo it's probably the only
place in the world where you can see a
Congo peacock in captivity but that
would be wonderful to see one in the
wild all right I hope you will find it
thank you thank you very much for taking
your time with us thank you